[Música]
Bienvenidos a Francia en foco su cita
con la actualidad francesa por las
pantallas de trans 24 que hoy realizamos
desde la comuna de chile en la periferia
de París porque aquí está la sede de
Francia 24 y también de su cadena
hermana radio Francia internacional
[Música]
estamos en la redacción en español de rf
y que está cumpliendo 40 años desde que
dirigió sus antenas hacia América Latina
en un momento crucial de la historia del
continente Alejandro Valente periodista
argentino acaba de jubilarse de radio
Francia internacional rfi y ya ha creado
un sitio Facebook para recuperar
recuerdos de esta mítica emisora allí
dirigió por 13 años el servicio en
español si bien los programas en lengua
de Cervantes existían desde la creación
de la radio en los años 30 solo bajo la
presidencia de françois en 1982 rfi
empezó a emitir hacia América Latina
radio Francia internacional van a
escuchar ustedes nuestro programa para
América y ahí se decidió realmente
multiplicar los recursos y aumentar
mucho la difusión en los diferentes
continentes y entre ellos el
latinoamericano que en ese entonces
estaba marcado por la presencia de
numerosas dictaduras habíamos vivido y
muchos de nuestros colegas habían
conocido la represión en países como
chile como Argentina como Uruguay como
Perú
entonces evidentemente estábamos muy
sensibilizados a la idea de poder
ofrecer una información de calidad a
quienes quisieran tener otras fuentes de
información que los medios dominados por
las dictaduras
hoy rf y en español es una redacción de
casi 30 personas donde se mezclan
acentos de ocho países diferentes a
través de seis noticieros al día
actualizan la información que entregan a
América Latina España y los Estados
Unidos hispanohablantes
Bienvenidos a una nueva ronda
informativa de radio Francia
internacional Gracias por escucharnos a
través de rf y mundo.com y nuestras
radios asociadas Bienvenidos a radio
Francia internacional después de la onda
corta de los 80 rfi pasó a emitir a
través del satélite hoy el gran medio de
difusión de radio Francia internacional
en el continente es además de su sitio
web y aplicaciones las radios asociadas
tenemos actualmente cerca de 700 radios
asociadas en todo el continente
americano que nos difunden total o
parcialmente todo lo que producimos
particularmente los los noticieros que
es lo que más interesa toda nuestra
radios y ese es el principal vector que
tenemos de difusión actualmente junto
obviamente a internet y las aplicaciones
el maquillaje forma parte de los deberes
de los periodistas de rfi desde hace
cuatro años después de la llegada de
internet El último gran desafío de la
cadena ha sido su asociación con nuestro
canal de televisión France 24 en español
pues ambos Son miembros de Francia
medios mundo están en un papel
la emisora elabora tres programas y
media Es decir que son difundidos en
radio y televisión todo un desafío
sabía que encontrar un compromiso no
porque en la radio
no utilidades imágenes describes más y
en la tele tienes las imágenes entonces
tuvimos que igual renunciar un poquito a
recursos de cada medio para llegar a ese
compromiso y que funcionara
[Música]
escala en París Aída Palau
Bienvenidos a todos a este programa de
radio Francia internacional y de France
24 París abre sus puertas al sector no
solo los periodistas sino que los
técnicos de radio hoy están detrás de
las cámaras
después de formarse en un nuevo oficio
un estudio de televisión fue construido
además en el primer piso del edificio
con la radio filmada rfi en español
sigue la vanguardia de Una aventura
mediática y por ahora parece no sufrir
la crisis de los 40
durante casi tres décadas rfi estuvo en
la casa de la radio la sede de la radio
pública francesa sin embargo desde que
se unió a Francia 24 rf y en español
funciona aquí entre rf y Brasil y rfi
África los estudios han sido instalados
en el seno de la redacción para evitar
carreras y sobresaltos el informes de
Melisa barra
[Música]
Bienvenidos a este flash informativo de
radio Francia internacional Vanessa
lottone lo hacen los controles hoy es
martes el 18 de octubre 4 de la tarde en
París íbamos ya con las noticias
andreína flores Mi nombre es andreina
Flores soy la presentadora del noticiero
de Radio Francia internacional el día a
día aquí en la redacción de
comienza temprano en la mañana hacemos
lo que se llama una conferencia de
redacción y ahí decidimos los temas más
importantes que se van a tratar durante
todo el día y cómo se van a tratar si se
va a llamar a los corresponsales y lo
vamos a tratar aquí en París lo que
diferencia a radio Francia internacional
es que nosotros somos una radio global
una radio que puede tratar temas
africanos O sea que puede tratar temas
rusos de Ucrania de Europa pero dirigido
a la audiencia latinoamericana
[Música]
Hola Soy Mauricio la torre vengo de
Argentina y Soy el jefe de la redacción
de radiofrecuencia internacional en
español
somos más de 20 personas que venimos de
Horizontes muy diferentes desde México
hasta Argentina tenemos colegas que
vienen de Colombia de Venezuela de chile
es una reacción muy diversa la
diversidad de nuestra producción además
de todo lo que hacemos en los noticieros
se refleja en toda la producción de
programas que tenemos que van después de
los noticieros que son muy diversos en
las temáticas escultura ciencia salud
Ecología y Tenemos también muchos
invitados el invitado de radio Francia
internacional
radio Francia internacional
enfoque
noticias de América en rfi
aquí comienza el deportivo de radio
Francia internacional con Carlos Pizarro
en radio Francia internacional en
español estamos cumpliendo 40 años
informando y lo hacemos junto a la red
de radio y para conocer más sobre radio
Francia internacional estamos Con
quienes su directora hace 10 años y
también un antiguo periodista de rfi
cecil México
gracias por acompañarnos cuéntanos un
poco a nuestros televidentes lo que es
radio Francia internacional cuando nació
a los gallegos internacionales una
cadena de radio del grupo France
mediasmont pero no es solo radio es un
medio global radio internet y un poco de
televisión Es una radio que habla
francés y otros 16 idiomas extranjeros
es parte del sector audio público
francés y emite en el mundo entero en
las regiones hispanohablantes pero
también en la África francófona y en
Asia con idiomas como el camboyano el
chino y el vietnamita en total tenemos
16 idiomas y cuatro son del continente
africano Kiss guajili mandin
y llegó el español en 1982 dedicado a
América Latina Aunque el español estaba
ya y existía ya desde la creación
prácticamente de la radio en 1930 Cuál
es la importancia justamente de la
cadena en español Aló al principio hace
40 años porque de hecho el aniversario
número 40 corresponde a la juventud de
la redacción en español era una
redacción para América Latina en la que
se hablaba español y portugués se
reclutaban periodistas que estaban aquí
en París que venían de todo el
continente latinoamericano porque en esa
época los regímenes políticos en el
Continente suramericano e incluso en
Centroamérica eran en su mayoría
dictaduras no había libertad de
información
en esos países esperaban noticias
provenientes del extranjero sobre lo que
pasaba ahí y lo que ocurría afuera en el
mundo entero
ahí fue cuando rfi como radio francesa
de servicio público jugó un papel como
medio Informativo en países cerrados
Cuáles son los valores de radio Francia
internacional
como medio de servicio público los
equipos se componen de periodistas
independientes con su deontología que
verifican la información
en un mundo donde actualmente se mezcla
una información las noticias falsas la
manipulación la comunicación saber que
esta cadena francesa vehicula el
profesionalismo de sus equipos es un
punto muy importante para nosotros
también es una cadena francesa entonces
hablamos desde París contamos al mundo
lo que es Francia y lo que es el mundo
en Francia porque Francia es un país al
que vienen muchos artistas filósofos
escritores figuras políticas del mundo
entero Entonces el encuentro con esas
personalidades también hace parte de los
contenidos que difundimos en nuestra
cadena
internacional en español comenzó la
aventura también de hacer programas de
media o trimedia básicamente radio
televisión e internet Cómo se está
viviendo esta experiencia y sirve de
ejemplo para las otras cadenas de radio
Francia internacional los hombres el
conjunto de los contenidos de rfi en
español está presente en nuestros
entornos digitales tenemos contenidos
propios en video y eso nos ha llevado
también a la experiencia de la
televisión porque en el grupo
francemediamond hay una cadena de
televisión que se llama France 24 que
siendo un medio internacional tuvo la
idea de crear France 24 en español para
emitir en el Continente latinoamericano
Española
y ahí pensamos que en rfi hay español
hay personas que saben que conocen que
tienen ganas entonces ejecutamos los
equipos y trabajaron juntos actualmente
el renombre de rfi le ha ayudado a Franz
24 en español y los contenidos de rfi
están en France 24 en español con tres
programas semanales un programa cultural
un programa de comentarios sobre la
actualidad y un programa de grandes
entrevistas que se hacen aquí en París
Muchas gracias por esta entrevista
Muchas gracias y hasta aquí este
capítulo de Francia enfoco Muchas
gracias por su compañía y hasta una
próxima por las pantallas de trans 24 o
en 324.com
[Música]